we now turn to chapter seven
which is uh matrix examples and we'll
look at a bunch of matrices that come up
in applications
it's just to give you an idea of what
matrices that uh what what matrices
arise in practice what they look like
and also in many cases we'll look at
things like what does a row mean or a
column
or what does matrix-vector
multiplication mean
because that'll always be interesting
depending on the application
so we'll start with geometric
transformations
so a lot of geometric transformations uh
in 2d or 3d uh can be represented
via matrix multiplication so that looks
something like this just y
equals ax a is you think of a is a
matrix that carries out
uh the geometric transformation so
here's an example
consider the mapping or transformation
that rotates a vector by
theta radians so here's a vector x
and it gets rotated over to uh theta
radians
got the same same norm but it's been
rotated
and it's been rotated by theta radians
and of course in the mathematically
positive direction
that means counterclockwise okay
so that's a that's a rotation mapping
and it turns out it has the form y
equals ax
now to get uh to get the entries of a
there are lots and lots of ways to do it
but a very simple one
is to do things like this when you have
y
equals ax if x is equal to e1 the first
unit vector
then y is going to be the first it's
going to be the first column of a
so for example if i took e1 that's this
vector here
and i rotate it by theta radians i get
to this
this vector and sure enough this
distance
is the cosine of theta that's our first
entry here
and this height here is sine theta
and that's here okay and to get the
second column
we look at a e2 so remember that when
you have a matrix a and you multiply by
e2
the second unit vector what you get is
the second column so
let's take e2 e2 is this vector
and we rotate it theta radians whoops my
mistake that's
a little bit too long but there we go so
we take that
and then we say what what are the
coordinates of that vector well
the x coordinate or x one coordinate
here
is going to be minus the sine theta and
so there you go that's that one
and then the height here of this thing
here
over here is going to be cosine theta
and so that gives you this thing
and by the way a matrix like this is
called a rotation matrix for obvious
reasons because
it rotates vectors by theta radians okay
this is just one example
there are a couple of others if you take
a look in the book you'll see more
for example reflection through a plane
things like that
and rotation matrices are used in lots
and lots of applications
in mechanics in um lots and lots lots of
areas
in graphics for example when you're uh
working out
you know what does something look like
from a certain angle okay
the next big group of examples we're
going to look at
is pretty generic it's called select
doors and
i'll tell you what a select door is so a
matrix is a select or if each of its
rows
has exactly one one and all other
entries are zero
another way to say that is that each row
is a unit vector
uh transposed so here's a select door
i'll just make one for you
like this uh right so there you go
okay so there's a there's a 3x3 select
or matrix
and if i multiply this by x1
x2 x3 that's a vector what i what comes
out
is that's x3 because i'm just going
across here and down here
then i get x1 and i get x3 and
what it says is if you think of this as
y and y
equals ax then what ax gives you is each
entry of that
if that's y each entry is one of the x's
so each
what it is is that selecting and it's
selecting from the entries of x
right they could be repeated so for
example here x3 shows up there and it
also shows up there
so uh that's how that works um and so
multiplying
by uh a a vector uh
basically selects different entries okay
so here's a
here's a practical example from if you
like signal processing or time series
um here's the matrix a and it's an m by
2m
matrix and it looks like this um
lots of ways to interpret it so the
first row
is e1 transpose the second row is e3
transpose the third is going to be e5
transpose
and so on so if you imagine what happens
when you multiply this by a vector
x here's what you get it will take
the first entry in the first component
of ax
then it will take x3 that's the third
entry of x
then x5 and so on and so for example if
x was a time
series uh then this would be referred
the slang would is you would say that
the time series has been down
sampled 2x meaning i'm taking the first
the third the fifth the seventh and so
on
and so that's that's with that so you
would be able to look at that matrix and
say ah
that represents if you multiply it by a
vector that's down sampling
for example but this comes up all over
the place in a lot of image processing
you'd get the same thing like image
cropping would be a select door
right so if i have an image represented
by a big long vector and i want to
uh do things like crop to some smaller
portion of it
i'm just selecting various pixels and
again it would
a would be a select or matrix okay so
this will come up
we'll see this in a lot of applications